es ist so ich kann natürlich jetzt hier
nur für Baden-Württemberg reden weil
Baden-Württemberg hat ein anderes Modell
wie gewählt wie die anderen Bundesländer
Baden-Württemberg geht nur nach dem
Grundwert das heißt das Grundstück wird
genommen wie es eben Grundbuch drin
steht in der Größe und dann wird es
multipliziert mit dem
Bodenrichtwert der pro Gebiet festgelegt
wird von Gutachterausschuss das ist z.B
in meinem Fall ein Bodenrichtwert von
1050 € der Quadratmeter Freiburg ist
teuer ja Freiburg ist teuer das heißt
wenn sie so rechnen ganz einfach ich
habe einen Grundstück von fast 2500
Quadratmeter das klingt natürlich
wahnsinnig viel ist es auch ein schönes
Kunststück wir haben das 1986 gekauft
und
und diesen kleinen relativ kleines Haus
eigentlich was da drauf steht aber das
spielt keine Rolle des Schauspielerin
keine Rolle dann geht nur nach dem
Grundstück so und das Problem ist ganz
einfach das nicht berücksichtigt wird
zum Beispiel dass ein Bachlauf dabei ist
wo man also gar nicht dran bauen kann
oder dass ein Weg zum Haus führt der
wird genauso gerechnet als wenn es
Grundstück wäre also mit 1050 Euro der
Quadratmeter das heißt es muss alles
rausgerechnet werden das macht das
Finanzamt nicht damit den habe ich
geschrieben habe gesagt guckt auf dass
das an ist kann ich nicht sein was ihr
hier mir
berechnen wollt und dann habe ich ein
nettes Schreiben zurückgekriegt nö
Grundbuch steht das drin und das wird
bei uns auch berechnet das heißt auf
deutsch ich muss in diesem Fall ein
Gutachter bestellen der der dieses der
das rausrechnet sozusagen das sind
natürlich dann sage ich jetzt mal
rundkosten von 3000 € die auf mich
zukommen nur für den Gutachter nur um
festzustellen was eigentlich richtig
wäre was ich auch spannend finde ist ähm
das Finanzamt schaut ins grundbuchein
und sieht da was da steht aber hier
werden über 80 Millionen Bürger es sind
eigentlich nur 60 die letztendlich dann
Grundstück vielleicht auch haben die
werden jetzt so aufgefordert eben dann
Ihre Angaben zu machen also können sie
es ja eigentlich aber sie wissen das auf
dem Bürger genau das ist die
grundsteuererklärung die jetzt jeder
noch leisten muss jetzt haben sie
erfahren und ich finde diese Zahlen die
sie uns da mitgebracht haben
normalerweise sind so ein bisschen was
über 400 Euro plötzlich explodiert diese
Zahlung
und bei uns in unserem Fall ist es also
so sind als wäre die neue Grundsteuer
14.211 € und 83 Cent
ich da Gedanken gemacht wie soll man
sowas bezahlen ich habe schon gesagt ich
bin Rentner wir haben das Haus 86
gekauft haben damals mit Kredit das
Ganze finanziert als ich dann in die
Rente ging war die was abbezahlt
sozusagen das was eigentlich der
Steuerzahler will dass der Rentner
vorsorgt ja das haben wir eigentlich
gemacht und jetzt käme mich sollte ich
14000 € Grundsteuer zahlen deswegen sind
im Monat können Sie rechnen 1200 €
kunststeuer und das ist natürlich jetzt
kann man natürlich sagen okay das ist
ein großes Grundstück aber Sie können
ihn gerade jetzt was Freiburg angeht und
den Bodenrichtwert angeht der ist
relativ hoch in Freiburg die Mieten sind
relativ hoch und das Spiel alles eine
Rolle auch für den Mieter das wird oft
vergessen weil die der die Grundsteuer
wird ja umgelegt auf die Karte umgelegt
werden auf die Miete das heißt ich habe
zum Beispiel einen ein Nachbar der hat
einen Grundstück und drei Familienhaus
steht auf dem Grundstück der hat eine
der hat ausgerechnet er muss 7 um 500
bezahlen es sind drei Mieter im Haus da
kommt auf jeden Mieter
zweieinhalbtausend Grundsteuer dazu zu
seiner Miete
ie denn Wahnsinns Zahlen ich will mal
bei ihrem Beispiel sehr ein bisschen
mich gerade auch so eindringlich
beschrieben im Prinzip haben sie sich
ein Lebenstraum erfüllt sie haben ihr
ganzes Leben gearbeitet damit sie als
Rentner mal sagen können dass es
abgezahlt wir haben eine Sicherheit wir
haben irgendwie auch unsere Schuld damit
erbracht wir sind jetzt in Sicherheit
und dürfen unseren Lebensabend genießen
mir scheint das jetzt total zu wackeln
also wie sollte das so kommen und wir
kommen dazu sie werden sich auch dagegen
aber wie können Sie das Stemmen womit
rechnen Sie was sind ihn da auch für
Gedanken nachts durch den Kopf durchs
Herz gegangen als sie erstmal für diese
Summe standen also es ist es ist so
deshalb bin ich eigentlich auch hier bei
mir geht's darum dass die Leute einfach
mal rechnen es gibt also wenn ich mich
mit Leuten auch unterhalten habe jetzt
in Freiburg und habe gesagt habt ihr mal
gerechnet was ihr neue Grundstücke nee
wir haben und wenn ich gesagt habe
dadurch man informiert wir haben den
Zettel ausgefüllt also sie haben die
Meldung gemacht als finanzamtam ja aber
nicht ausgerechnet
sondern die haben gesagt ich habe glaube
ich konnte das das Formular ausfüllen ja
und und insofern und dann wird natürlich
auch auf das Argument gebracht der
Hebesatz ist in Freiburg 600 das ist
auch relativ hoch und der Hebesatz
spielt eben auch noch eine Rolle also
wenn ich soll ich mal erklären wie der
sich errechnet
dass sie dann noch mal beim Finanzamt
anrufen aber es ist nett dass sie das
Mitbringen aber das ist ein
kompliziertes Rechensystem und sie haben
sich da eingefügt ihr natürlich raus ist
eigentlich an alle anderen fuchst euch
da lieber auch mal ein weil sonst kommt
ein ganz großer Schlag mit dem mir
gerade nicht rechnet nee weil einfach
viele sagen ach das mit dem Hebesatz
machen und so weiter nur die Stadt kann
gar nicht so weit runter gehen vom
hebelsatz und hatte keine Einnahmen mehr
in der Grundsteuer weil er das auch für
alle Häuser dann betrifft als auch für
Hochhäuser und so weiter
sind ihre Summe auf 10.000 das ist das
was man da könnte also sagen wird
reduziert von 600 400 dann müsste ich
7000 bezahlen da kann ich immer noch
nicht bezahlen so was heißt mein meine
Sache ist einfach dass ich sage die
ganze die ganze Berechnung muss
eigentlich auf den Kopf gestellt werden
und deshalb
[Musik]
ärgert mich auch wenn ich habe also
schreiben auch von der Landesregierung
hier die sagen jetzt warte doch mal ab
ja das wird gar nicht so toll kommen wie
heißt so heiß gegessen wie es gekocht
wird oder so und das ist einfach was
soll man erwarten also man muss
eigentlich rechts jetzt schon sagen das
System ist falsch so und dann muss das
System muss ich geändert werden und da
kann man jetzt sagen jetzt warte mal
noch ein bisschen ab jetzt schon
irgendwie besser werden
ich finde weil das ist mir jetzt selber
gerade erst aufgegangen viele Leute
beschäftigen sich gar nicht damit weil
sie sagen ich habe ja sowieso keinen
Grund Eigentum ich bin ja nur Mieter
betrifft mich nicht aber über die Umlage
über die Umlage wird ist das im Prinzip
eine deutlicher
Mieterhöhung für alle Leute über die
Nebenkosten und die werden wir zahlen
müssen das heißt genau genommen betrifft
es alle und es ist nahezu perfide den
Leuten zu sagen irgendwie ja jetzt warte
erstmal ab das ist ja wie ein einlull
nach dem Motto jetzt mal kein Aufstand
machen und dann ist es in Kraft und dann
gucken sich alle ihre Miete vielleicht
weil es wird ja dann auch Mieterhöhungen
geben müssen die ja auch eigentlich zu
hoch sind es halt haben sie ein Verdacht
warum macht man das in Baden-Württemberg
im Land der Häuslebauer warum machen
sowas macht es ist natürlich einfach bei
in anderen Bundesländern ist es so dann
wird das Haus mit berücksichtigt ja und
dann muss dann muss man natürlich das
Haus angucken da musste was anderes
von 1956 so und das ist natürlich was
anderes wenn bei mir eine wieder drauf
stehen würde wäre die Grundsteuer
genauso groß das heißt das Haus spielt
gar keine Rolle es ist natürlich es ist
natürlich für das Land einfacher zu
sagen wir berechnen und da brauchen sie
nicht keine Gedanken über das Haus
machen sondern sie rechnen einfach nur
Grund
der Grund ist der Grundwert ist das also
richtig ist mal die Quadratmeter ist
gleich Grundstück daraus kann ich meine
größeres Ziel sondern sie dazu gedrängt
werden dass sie etwas von ihrem
Grundstück verkaufen will man eigentlich
sie aus ihrem Haus raus haben weil
Wohnraum ist knapp man findet kaum mehr
Lösungen wie erklären Sie sich das es
gibt eine Aussage vom Finanzministerium
das heißt es entspricht damit
langjährigen Forderungen der
Umweltverbände zum Thema Flächennutzung
das heißt man will er effizientere
Nutzung bebaubare Flächen nur bebaubare
Flächen ist ja immer noch die Frage wo
ist es möglich es ist ja nicht überall
möglich zum Beispiel bei meinem
Grundstück selbst der so groß ist ist es
nicht möglich zu bauen ja und das ist
immer das es wird aber immer gesagt ja
gut wie sie jetzt auch vermuten dass man
sagt ja das schaffe ich wieder Bauland
so aber selbst jetzt wenn man mal wenn
man diesen Gedanken weiter spinnt könnte
auch sagen wie schnell muss ich den
bauen um in 2025 auszukommen
einigermaßen rauszukommen aus dieser ja
das funktioniert gar nicht auf eine
Wärmepumpe muss man drei Jahre warten ja
genau
Baden-Württemberg einfach das falsche
Modell gewählt das haben wir viele
andere Bundesländer machen es anders und
am Ende glaube ich muss auch der Druck
bei der Kommune da sein dass man nicht
mehr Einnahmen damit erwirtschaftet dann
Hebesatz so wird dass die Einnahmen
gleich bleiben und das Angebot der fairn
ist denn wir wollen ja dass Leute
Immobilieneigentum erwerben genau wie
sie sagt aus Altersvorsorge Grünten aus
Gründer finanziell Stabilität also wir
wollten eigentlich ganz sicher ob man
das will also ich weiß ich würde jedes
einzelne FDP das noch will aber man hört
ja gerade z.B auch aus dem aus der Ecke
der Grünen ist ja auch die Frage des
Wohnraums genauso eine die diskutiert
wird irgendwie dass man die neuen die
Menschen aus dem Eigenheim eigentlich
raus haben will weil es ist ja viel zu
viel Platz und da muss viel zu viel
geheizt werden wieder also viel zu viel
Energie Verbrauch angeblich wenn man dem
Einfamilien wohnen Haus wohnt wir kennen
ja auch hier ist geht der Trend ja quasi
zur menschenhaltung was der irgendwann
werden wir noch erleben wenn die Grünen
noch lange in der Regierung sind dass
wir zugeteilt bekommen wie viel Räume
wir noch bisschen bewohnen dürfen und
das das ist ja auch wir sagen es wird ja
auch von vielen Ideologen schon genauso
ausgesprochen dass das Ende des
Eigenheims quasi also erst nimmt man
dass das Auto weg und dann nimmt man uns
das Eigenheim weg dass das ja eine
politische Strategie ist die manche für
toll finden ne also eben Stichwort
zurück zum Lagerfeuer das wird aber
nicht rasieren da entsiedeln war ja alle
ländlichen Regionen also man kann nicht
der einen Seite sagen wir wollen
strukturschwache ländliche Regionen
unterstützen und dann sagen ihr dürft er
nicht mehr wohnen oder mobil sein
lieber freundlich das Lagerfeuer haha
tatsächlich
schon mal die Rechnung angestellt wir
haben gerade gesagt egal ob Eigentum
oder Mieter das kann alles ich lebe in
einer kleinen Siedlung noch und das ist
ein sehr sehr kleines Grundstück das
sind gerade mal 120 Quadratmeter
eingeengt in andere einige andere Häuser
für mich könnte sogar so sein dass es
ein Tick en günstiger wird ich habe es
noch nicht genau nachgerechnet aber da
mache ich mir jetzt keine großen Sorgen
es sind
vielleicht niemand braucht das ist auch
noch Menschen gibt
eins und zwei ich wollte nur mal ganz
kurz sagen bei mir ist natürlich
riesiges Grundstück wo jeder sagen kann
dann kann er das auch bezahlen so
ungefähr ne ich mein so ein bisschen
Neid gibt's ja dann auch noch ne aber
ich habe jetzt mal hier ein Beispiel von
einem Einfamilienhaus in Freiburg das
ist keine besondere gegen das ist im
Stadtteil Mooswald da hat man damals hat
die Stadt den Leuten dein häusliche
hingestellt und ein Garten dazu und hat
ihm gesagt er könnte euch sogar noch ein
bisschen selbst versorgen Kartoffeln
anbauen und so weiter ne der hat bis
jetzt 200 € 30 € bezahlt und muss jetzt
2150 bezahlen ist das jetzt ein kleiner
Beispiel
ist jetzt extrem groß
weil es keine Willen Gegend
also was ist ihr Plan B sollte das jetzt
alles so kommen was er wegen sie den
Umzug den Verkauf das ist äh ich weiß
nicht ob ich es verkaufen kann wenn
derjenige weiß dass er 14.000 bezahlen
muss
deshalb kämpfe ich eigentlich weil ich
einfach sage es geht nicht so ich sage
anderes es kann nicht sein so das ist
und deshalb bin ich hier und deshalb tue
ich auch viele Leute einfach ermutigen
uns ganz wichtig ist sobald der erste
Bescheid kommt muss Einspruch eingelegt
werden
Bescheid bekommen der erste Bescheid ist
ganz wichtig der zeigt nur die
Quadratmeterzahl und der Boden wird da
steht doch nicht drin was ich zahlen
muss und viele Leute tun da noch nicht
dagegen einsprachige und das ist genau
der wunde Punkt ich muss da schon einige
wenn ich die Summe erst bekommen habe im
zweiten ist es schon zu spät weil ich
muss schon gegen die Grund gegen die
Grundlage Vorgehen also ganz schnell
handeln und sie machen sich höre ich
raus noch nicht so Gedanken wie geht's
weiter weil ich habe auch eingangs
gesagt Sie haben noch Hoffnung sie geben
da nicht auf und sie lassen sich jetzt
von diesen 14000 € dieser hurentenzahl
erstmal keine Angst
vielleicht enteignet werden oder was
oder ich werde als Rentner wenn ich
bezahlen muss 1200 pro im Monat das kann
ich nicht werde ich als
Sozialhilfeempfänger wer auch eine
alternative ja aber wie traurig oder
irgendwie ihr Leben lang gearbeitet sich
diesen Traum erfüllt
deshalb glaube ich auch nicht dran ja
die Hoffnung ist auch nur einer von
vielen ja also ich sagen das werden die
Leute ja nicht einfach hinnehmen das
wird erst betrifft es wird ja tausende
von Menschen betreffen die genau
dasselbe Problem haben die jetzt noch
nicht wissen dass sie ein Problem haben
nehmen Sie das mit Herr Herbst einfach
in die Parteispitze mit rein die
Bundesregierung kann da was machen
Grundsteuer betrifft alle besonders
drastisch in Baden-Württemberg und hier
ein besonders drastischer Fall von einem
Häusle Bauer ist nicht aber zumindest
Besitzer der dann eigentlich nicht weiß
ich glaube das sind die Länder gefordert
eine vernünftigen vernünftiges Modell zu
finden da gibt es ja unterschiedliche
Modelle wieder einzelne Länder haben ich
sag mal das 60 Modell ist auch nicht das
allerbeste aber es führt nicht zu
solchen extrem Entwicklungen ich finde
es muss schon berücksichtigt werden
welche Art von Gebäude darauf steht weil
sonst ist es einfach unfair und wie
gesagt wir wollen niemanden das Eigentum
wecken das kann nicht Ziel einer Politik
sein weder Bundesregierung noch Landes
Regierung noch auf kommunale leben
würden sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie